what's going on you little gentrified
brain wiggas I got allergies bro and one
of my eyes is a little bit shorter than
the other one [__] it dude welcome to
this past weekend this past
[Music]
[Applause]
weekend
[Music]
you hear
that you hear
that that is Army of
angels that is Army of angels from
epidemic
sounds and that is uh that's that type
of music where you you know something
crazy is happening in a in a film you
know like like they got the art and
they're running out of the museum or or
um somebody's running through a tunnel
wearing like a you know like a helmet
and they're looking
for um they're looking for a bad guy or
something like that you know that's
where the action is and that is called
Army of
angels and that is uh that is action
music that's a sound that plays in your
head when you you know are late for work
and you're still trying to make a
smoothie really fast in the blender you
know when you're throwing a bunch of
[__] in there and [__] you know getting
all [__] jazzed up and you know you
got the banana in there and you're
trying to put some peanut butter in
there and some milk and you don't have
any milk so you're [__] putting water
in there and you're eating a jacked up
[__] rural New York smoothie you know
probably has four grams of protein 70
grams of sugar
and uh and that's what you're having and
that's the kind of music that's playing
in your head uh when those types of
things are occurring or at least that's
how I feel man welcome to this past
weekend guys it is Monday and if it
sounds like it's April 24th
2017s that's because it is it is that
date that is where we are in the in time
um and I have allergies bro I'll admit
it dude you know I'm not the kind of guy
who you know just stands around redey
you know with snot kind of hanging out
of his nose like uh you know like uh you
know like a couple
of couple of Asian fellas or kids
hanging off a you know the side of a
bicycle or
something I um I got allergies dude I'll
admit it I got them I fall victim you
know I can be a tough guy but also I can
fall victim to to uh to uh to pollen you
know really put you in your place it
really put you in your place when you
think you're a badass and then you have
to sit down um and really gather
yourself before you sneeze because you
got issues with pollen so that's where I
am I'm in Sacramento California I'm
actually in the kitchen of a residence
in uh motel hotel and if you've never
been to a residence in it's a very uh
BAS basic um but comfortable type of
place you know it's it's your you know
middle of the road type of a motel hotel
and I've been here this weekend in
Sacramento um
Sacramento good place I feel like to get
uh to get socks to get new socks and
maybe to get murdered or not murdered
but attacked I could see somebody just
hitting you for no reason in
Sacramento it kind of seems like the
kind of place where karma
is um prevalent it seems Karma heavy
like it any point you could get jacked
or hit by somebody or a bird a bird
wouldn't [__] on you in Sacramento but
it might come down and bite your [__]
neck you know maybe a couple of black
birds or mixed Birds might [__] come
down and you know just just [__] just
just slap you with that wing you know or
[__] rip a mole off your back with
their talons you know it's got that kind
of it's got that kind of edge to it it's
got like a hillbilly edgely you know
it's got that hillbilly Edge but also
kind of a thug everybody looks like kind
of like a mixed baby that grew
up um but it's good man it's real people
and I love real people man and I think
it may have it may be the city where I
ran into the
most um like like fans and Friends where
I felt like a real connection I mean I
just really really relate uh to the
people around this type of environment
man so I had a great weekend except for
these allergies got Daddy
down um you know I'd rather be snotting
out of my nose than out of my pecker
though that's the old saying you know
I'd rather have allergies than uh
sexually transmitted um diseases and
that you know and no offense if somebody
has those you
know some of that's part of
nature excuse me but yeah if you can see
on the YouTubes I'm in the kitchen right
now of a Marriott Residence in and I've
got some uh some new dates for you I'm
coming to Phoenix Arizona in two weeks
you can come and get a look at my
Straight Up d uh not really but you can
come and be a part of the show man I'd
love to have you come out that's May 5th
and 6th at standup live in Phoenix
Arizona um I'm really excited about that
May 25th through 28th I'll be in Tampa
Florida at sidesplitters June 1st
through 4th I'll be in Pittsburgh at the
Pittsburgh improv June 23rd and 24th New
York City I hope to catch up on jump on
the Opie uh Opie show there as well and
then June 30th we are doing a fundraiser
show in Wyoming Illinois it's a small
town uh the tickets will go online this
week for that it's about an hour from
Peoria um not too far from the Quad
Cities so if you're in uh Illinois and
you want to come check that out or
you're in Iowa come on over it's going
to be a it's going to be a really good
time small town show I'm excited about
that all right man let's get into the
weekend man it was uh it's been a it's
been a chill one you know I'm at this
residence in I got into a little bit of
a fracus at the pool
here um they got some guys I guess been
staying here for about a month you know
some dude who's real like
tall like beer belly like almost amazing
amount of beer belly for his height and
he just talks he knows
everything and uh and he was grilling
bro he's been grilling all weekend at
the pool at the you know who uses the
grill at a [__] Marriott Residence in
I didn't know they had a grill and this
dude's out there he's inviting friends
over he's got [__] they got some lady
like an older lady out there twerking
about maybe about 48 years old um you
know uh blond hair
party you know uh just kind of shake
shaking her just like not really shaking
her just kind of bending over and
holding onto a table and then just
shaking everything you know it's one
thing to kind of shake your ass and do
that fancy ass work you know and to
really get yourself you know gting but
it's another thing just to kind of bend
over and just [__] move your whole
body at once like it's not the same it
almost looks like somebody's hurt or
something you know like they got uh like
their whole body is itching but they're
not allowed to scratch it or something
like they've been you know they've been
told they can't scratch themselves so
they're just trying to scratch their
body against the air by moving their
body around so that's kind of what this
lady was doing out by the
pool and of course you got all these
fellas drinking and this dude's [__]
grilling potatoes you know
like I I don't know man I mean I've been
in some pretty gutter [__] but this
dude's out there like
this [__] know it all grilling potats
you
know so I'm trying to go in there and
talk to them just I mean they were just
kind of rul in the pool I guess I got a
little mouthy um but things calmed down
and uh it was just awkward it's awkward
to see somebody you know grilling out at
a at a residence
in but here I am man here I am I'm in uh
in Sacramento a lot of missing people a
lot of people here look like missing
persons you know I put this on Twitter
yesterday and I just everybody here I
kind of you know I love those shows
where uh where people are missing of
I've always been a fan of um of missing
people of buried treasure you know I
can't even sleep at night really unless
I've seen a new episode of a show where
somebody is missing or where there's a
treasure that uh hasn't been found I've
just have an obsession with that you
know I found some fingers by the in the
woods when I was
young um and so maybe that spurned some
of that some of that behavior but that's
always been a part of my life I love the
missing so if you are missing you know
or you know somebody that's missing dude
um I'd love to hear about that or if you
know somebody that went missing we can
talk about that uh next week I'd love to
know if you've ever been missing as well
if you are someone who went into hiding
you know or who decided to skip out on
you know a prison sentence or hide from
their family or something like that I'd
love to to get to you know I'd love to
have you call in hit the hotline so that
I could uh get into that and learn more
about uh what your life has been like uh
we're getting close to having some
guests guys I hope next week to have a
guest so I know I bring things up on the
show that I want to do I appreciate you
guys bearing with me um it's a struggle
because some of these weeks on the road
keep popping up and I'm in a [__]
kitchenet okay if you're on YouTube you
can see me I'm taping this [__] I don't
even have my mic stand I have my I have
the top of it but not the bottom I have
this thing propped up in a coffee pot
that I took the top off of so we're
doing what we can I got
allergies I I just want to shoot myself
in the [__] head with an EpiPen
anyhow
49503 if you are missing or if you know
someone who has been missing I'd love
for you to call in um I remember when I
was young we were playing hide and go
seek and a boy went and hid and uh and
they never found we never no one ever
found him or heard from him so I
sometimes wonder what happened to that
uh that boy what else man um I read this
dude
that they had some conjoined
twins I believe they're from Mexico and
now living in Connecticut that's a real
uh ju toos I think um I don't know what
that is but that is uh and they don't
want to be separated conjoined twins
refusing to be separated
and you know what that makes me feel it
made me feel good when I heard that
because I'm tired sometimes of us doing
whatever science kind of says we should
do you know the doctors tell them well
you know you have a better chance of
living if you
separate but you know but do but what's
their life going to be like you know I
mean I look at you know I I'm not in
this scenario but I just you know I
think it's kind of beautiful to stay in
it to stick it out you're conjoined you
got your [__] you can high five
yourself but somebody else at the same
time there's something beautiful about
that and to know that um that you're in
this together through thick or thin
There's Something Beautiful about that
that you know what don't separate us
we're going to see what we can do we're
going to make it through this together I
think that's pretty beautiful man so
that story really resonated with me um I
hope they stay conjoined I hope they
stick it out and you know what if they
go to heaven they go to heaven together
you know and I think there's something
beautiful about that man it's like when
somebody gets uh you know it's like if
you had a little person that was hooked
on to you and you didn't and you got
them cut off you know I wouldn't do that
i' I'd say we'll ride or die you know
this is my friend shotgun and we [__]
we're going in we're going into life
together thought that was interesting um
another thing in the news I saw the
Confederate monuments in New
Orleans and I know this has been
happening in other cities are being
taken down there's been a lot of issue
back and forth there about these
Confederate monuments uh Robert E Lee
other uh Confederate uh
statues and uh soldiers that that it's a
racist you know that people feel and
predominantly black people but also
black and white people feel that it's
not you know that you see this leader of
a southern Army and that it's uh that
it's racist and I can understand the
rebel flag like I get that you know
because there are people that really
associate that um heavily with with
racism um but I I you know I'm I'm just
not a proponent of the of Bringing Down
the Confederate statues because if
you're going to do that then there's
statues in New Orleans where there are
like slaves there's slaves and it talks
about like you know when indentured
servants and slaves came to New Orleans
um there's some I believe in the Mahalia
Jackson Park right there in Armstrong
Park then I'd like to see those statues
gone because I don't want to remember
that I didn't have anything to do with
slavery you know like I'm sorry I think
it's horrible you know I wouldn't
probably want to be a slave I don't
think I mean maybe in some instances but
not
overall um but it's like when do we just
like it is do we just take everything
away that bug somebody you know and I
know that you know remembering slavery
isn't bugging somebody it's bigger than
that but you know I don't want to see I
don't want to see things that remind me
of negative stuff you know like I just
feel like we're headed down this road
where we're never going to get to a
place where everybody's happy you know
like I never walk down the street and
I'm totally fired up you know if that if
we're doing that then get rid of all my
ex-girlfriends
you know get rid of uh get rid of the
dude that used to make me bury his poops
in the yard when I was growing up he
actually he passed away so that's
already that's that's a mute point but
like at what point do we stop you know
getting rid of just anything that bugs
us so I don't know I you know I just I
don't agree with that I agree with
taking down things that really are
Surefire of
racism but you know the South had its
own
Army I just I I feel like having some
tradition is okay I just feel like cuz
at a certain point we're headed down a
road that you can't you're never going
to be able to do it all let's completely
erase history then because history's
always pissed somebody off you know
something pisses somebody off
everywhere what else dude I've been
thinking about the future man and I want
people to call in too if they have some
thoughts about this the future dude and
you know what I'm talking about you know
what's next and it kind of Spooks me out
bro you know I feel like we are so I
almost dropped my phone in the
pool um here at the residence in and uh
and I like flipped I like felt my whole
body like kind of seizure up and I was
like wow like I don't really get that
feeling unless it's my phone you know
like if I saw like a friend fall in the
pool I'd be like uh they'll probably be
okay not knowing if they could could
swim or whatever they'll probably be all
right but when you see a
phone about to go in you're like oh my
God it's going to die like that's what I
felt like it's going to die it I mean it
as if it's as if it were more than a
machine that's that's what concerned me
I was like this that I thought of it as
more than a
machine um anyhow so I'm just a little
bit worried about the future man when do
we stop
technology at what point do we shut it
down when it's
not like when it it's not helping us
anymore you know like when is that like
I can understand in some Fields you know
in some of the medical fields and stuff
like
that but when do we like self-driving
cars you know um there the trucking
industry they say will be gone like
CrossCountry truckers you know um a lot
of stepdads probably a lot of stepdads
doing that work when does that end
because if we allow self-driving cars
then you just have thousands and tens
and hundreds of thousands of men and
women that are going to be out of work
like I don't see the benefit there like
at what point is it not helping us to be
human I feel like we're there right now
I'd love to know some of you guys'
thoughts on that I feel like we're at a
spot in time where where where
technology isn't helping us as humans
anymore it's just helping us to
create
basically machines and and a future that
has
us not as really a big part of the
picture so that's where I'm at with it
man I have a lot of concern there you
know I I I also think that TVs are too
clear I'm watching this the other day
I'm I'm trying to watch something Dances
with Wolves you know the movie about
it's about a warrior whenever he goes
to um he meets a woman and there
somebody has um [__] wolves I think I
can't even remember guys it's uh sorry
it's 3:00 a.m. I'm a little bit out of
it but bro the movie was so clear I felt
like I was watching like home videos
from Oklahoma you know of like a civil
war Reena I'm like this is it just it
didn't hold it wasn't the same so I just
wonder if anybody else feels that way
like am I the only person who I just
think televisions are too clear like I
want to I want to know that it's a story
I don't want to feel like I'm looking
into like a weird window where it
doesn't seem like a story so those are
just some of my thoughts on uh on the
future man that's where I'm at I know
I'm rambling a little bit today guys I'm
going to get through
this um and I want to apologize too man
I know that you know I've said again
that I that there's some things I want
to do with this podcast I want to get to
some other levels I want to get some
guests um and I haven't gotten to those
things yet for you guys and I want to um
I had a a guy this weekend at one of the
shows and he was really nice after the
shows we were talking I met a lot of
great people here in
Sacramento um went downtown beautiful
downtown um but I met a guy and I was
like he's and he likes the podcast and I
said well thank you for listening you
know I'm trying to figure it out and and
you know trying to figure out what I'm
doing sometimes and he goes just do what
you say you're going to do that's what
he said and at first it kind of struck
me a little bit like a strong thing to
say but then I was like he's right man
you know if I'm going to connect um with
people and I'm going to want to share
and have you know listeners share with
me you know I got to do the things that
I say I'm going to do um so I do want
you to know that I'm making an effort
that I'm trying to get it done um that
I'm trying to create you know good legit
content for you guys uh where we can you
know move forward and learn some [__]
together it's been a rocky year for me
um you know with the Native American
child that could have been that kind of
sent my feelings into a whirlwind um
with the
electrocution um you know with just the
belittlement out there in Los Angel
being a a southern guy you know they
they don't want
us they don't want us man they want to
take down the statues they want to take
down the humans I feel like a lot of
times um but I'm going to try to do the
things that I say I'm going to do I've
had a lot of amazing calls from you guys
and I'm going to try to get to most of
them that are relevant you know there's
one where it's um a guy and his kid just
talking in the car for two and a half
minutes that's there's nothing there you
know there's some where guys are making
up stories there's a couple where men
are jerking off in the distance or women
that sound like men that make male jerk
off sounds um there's a lot of stuff
going on but I got allergies right now I
got a lot going on today I want to get
this out to you guys I want to get to a
few
questions um you can support the podcast
if you want you can go uh and and and
grab the album 30 lb bag of hamster
bones it's still out there and uh and
what else there some other cool stuff on
the on the website theo. comom store all
right man let's jump into a couple of
calls right here let's go hey what's up
Theo this is uh Chase I'm calling from
actually right outside New Orleans that
985 you heard me that 985 boy I I do
hear you chase man that's uh that's my
neck of the woods brother uh come come
across 104 I was calling in reference
you asked about if anybody's having
trouble about masturbation or stories
about bad jobs or something like that
well I had this job I actually really
liked it it was one of my favorite jobs
I was driving school bus for the parish
and um oh nice dude now the parish uh
Most states have counties uh Louisiana
we have parishes that's what they call
it there so it's the same thing um damn
this dude's pretty gangster bro if you
driving bus bro go
on it was basically awesome I saw the
sunrise every morning off every weekends
but there was this one aspect where the
high school kids you know like public
school in you know south Louisiana you
can kind of paint the picture in your
head but yeah really all the kids were
great except for this one and I really
kind of liked him and hated him because
like he was like a really smart sharp
dude like but he was
zingy ah you got zinged by the ch
children huh um I can relate to that man
I can relate to uh School Bus activities
that's for sure uh Chase when I was
young bro they we had I'll tell you this
story we had a boy on our school
bus who his daddy made him a wooden
shirt and I talk about this sometime in
my standup but his daddy had made him a
wooden shirt a shirt out of wood and not
even and not even teak or or balsom you
know those are malleable Woods uh This
Boy's shirt was made out of ply ply
wood um and the daddy was an Elvis and
personator and um and he the daddy was
an Elvis impersonator because well first
of all he was an alcoholic you know
because we only had you know
maybe few hundred people in our area we
didn't need a [__] Elvis dude you
know we
need you know we need gas G money and we
need ideas you know those are the top
two things we need nobody's hiring an
Elvis you know and [__] half of
everybody's uncle looks a little bit
like Elvis anyway so nobody's going to
go just get another Uncle uh for you
know whatever price he was charging but
anyway this man had broke his leg and
they set his leg in cement to fix it um
cheaper on the cheap you know but when
it when it and it healed up well
everybody assumed but when they but when
they broke the cement cast off they
broke it with a hammer ballpen hammer
and it re-broke his leg in a hip and
about two or three different spots maybe
at
least so then he was really effed up
they had to set most of his lower body
in uh in the cement except for where he
could urinate out of so uh but after
that he healed up he kind of had like
this wobble in his hips almost
ironically like Elvis Presley but anyhow
he had a uh three or four children and
one of them was a boy and the boy used
to vomit on the bus all the time because
the family didn't have a refrigerator
they only had a freezer and he would eat
ice
cream and he would the bus Rod would
shake and make him sick and he would
vomit up on the bus doing bus
vomit and uh and anyhow one one one one
week I was coming over from church
practice
um and the dad was in the garage and he
was making his son a uh a wooden shirts
a shirt out of wood and I went over and
I didn't know what he was doing you know
I thought he was building a [__]
biggest birdhouse I've ever seen you
know I'm thinking like damn this dude
this dude's trying to meet a pelican you
know so I go over and I see this
activity going on and uh I'm I'm looking
at him and the dad he he's like you want
to help me
out and I'm like I don't know what's
going on he's like I'm making my boy a
shirt you know and so I want to be
helpful you know I'm a young man but I'm
you know uh I'm you know fired up to try
and be helpful so I try and help but I
don't know how to make a shirt but
anyhow I came back 2 days later and that
was Christmas time I came back on
Christmas and we and I held the side of
this uh when he nailed his son into the
shirt and he made his
son a uh excuse me a
beautiful I mean pretty pretty pretty
beautiful wooden shirt out of plywood so
it's not it almost looked kind of
camouflage you know because of the ply
because of the different you know wood
particles that are in there but uh but
he wore it for a while some people spray
painted swas stickers on it on the
school bus as well um and nobody had
anything against juice people had just
seen that on pamphlets you know had
seen uh had seen the swas stickers on
pamphlets and stuff and so somebody drew
that you know we didn't even have any
Jewish people in our area even though my
mother dated a Jewish man for a while um
was the first Jewish man I ever met
actually this man zali was his
name still one of the neatest names I've
ever heard but anyhow uh that boy had
that shirt for a while and then some
people stole it from him um
with crowbars and made allegedly made a
uh baby crib out of the wood so that has
kind of a sweet ending but uh but what I
was answering there sorry to go into
that but what I was answering
was um was this gentleman's question
here uh on the school bus let's go back
to that story I don't know how I got
away from the school bus so so far but
that was a strange kid that rode my bus
was that boy uh in the wooden shirt who
used to do a lot of bus vomiting uh but
anyway go on Chase let's get back to you
every [__] day and it started the
very first day I ever picked him up well
he didn't skip a beat you know of course
smelling of weed steps right onto the
bus I'm a big fat dude you got to
understand this and he looks right at me
that's cool man I have some friends that
are pretty fat or different types of
sizes in their body go on so you got the
kid getting on the bus making fun of you
a
lot oh [__] is Peter Griffin driving
bus so that pretty much set the tone for
the rest of that whole entire school
year wow man so that's uh so you got the
kid getting on the bus he's raising hell
um so I was calling to see how would you
deal with a situation like that or you
just roll with the punches and enjoy
getting Zing by professional so all
right man well you know what I mean I'll
say this if uh if he's if he's quick
like that you might not want to go at
him you know um sometimes you just can't
compete if somebody's zinging you and
sometimes you just need to not try and
compete and just enjoy the fact that
they're zinging you bro you know I mean
if he gets really mean with it you could
ask him take him aside and be like look
man I I think it's I think you're a
funny funny dude you know respect that
in him because he probably takes a lot
of pride in being funny you know it
might be the only thing he has you know
he might not be real smart he might just
be funny like you know when you're a
funny kid I think you take a lot of
pride in that um but just ask him not to
be mean say look you can make fun of
whatever you want just you know if he's
really gripping at you something that's
really hurting your feelings or getting
into your feelings you know cuz you got
to drive a bus dude you can't be getting
bent out of shape cuz [__] you know
little Terry is zinging you and next
thing you know you're you know your fist
tailing you know 50 kids
around you know you got to keep it
together
together uh so yeah that's what I would
do man you know just let him have his
fun dude laugh with him um if you think
you got to go him maybe go back at him
you know U maybe you could ask some of
the other bus drivers what are some
popular terms that they use to make fun
of
children um we had a we had a man that
drove us to school shirtless one time
this man named Milford and he had a uh a
mix boy he had a boy that was mixed but
they tried to pretend like the boy was
not mixed so he had a boy that was uh
half black half white a son but they
tried to pretend like the boy had two
white parents and I always thought that
that was interesting and I also thought
my vision was bad for a while cuz I
would see him and be like damn my eyes
uh aren't seeing colors correctly I used
to think that but uh Chase thanks for
calling in there dude sorry I went off
on my own tangent um I'm at my wits end
right now and I'm high on
Claritin um I've been I've been uh put
putting down some Claritin recently uh
this weekend here in Sacramento is
Claritin country uh let's get into
another uh another question right here
man hey Theo I got a unique one for you
man I uh we got a lot in common in the
fatherhood Department my dad was 66 when
I was born okay wow his father was
66 uh when he was born my father was 70
when I was born so very similar and he
died when I was 16 same here and uh
right after that a year after that I
joined the Marine Corps got deployed
came home thank you for your service
brother came home and and uh had a hard
time readjusting so I kind of went down
a a shitty Road
um I got a couple questions for you
because I think you might be the only
person I've ever heard of that's got an
old ass dad like mine but uh how did you
uh how do you handle
with not having that Father Figure to go
to and do you feel any resentment
because I find myself find uh having
resentment towards him okay uh I'm going
to stop it there because that's a lot
right there um how did I handle not
having a dad um and did I feel any
resentment
uh you know the
resentment it's hard to have for me
because for me my father just wasn't
really there enough to resent him
so I can resent kind of him not being
there um but he just at a certain age
there's not a lot that they can even do
so like he couldn't even be there in a
physical capacity I mean my parents also
got divorced when I was seven and then I
only saw my father on the weekends but
you know he could only be there so much
in a physical capacity so so to have a
resentment towards him is really tough
um like I do resent the
situation um I resent his choice to have
children when he was that old but also
if he doesn't have kids I don't exist so
I have to be grateful for that for I
have to be grateful for my own life
because if I'm not grateful for my own
life then I'm not uh you know I'm not
even taking any stock in myself so so I
am I I do have resentment towards him
just for not being there but I don't
have resentment uh like small
resentments towards him because once he
wasn't there there's nothing really that
he could do and because of his age he
really couldn't be there um so I guess
there's some resentment there but not
like in every moment like I wish my dad
was here for this I wish I don't I don't
hold those resentments now unfortunately
what I do is I put a lot of pressure on
my mother you know I took a lot of
things out of my mother that should have
been probably a father's
responsibilities but but suddenly all
those male responsibilities switched to
my mother and I think the same thing
happens with a lot of uh kids that just
have a mother or just have one parent
you put the pressures or the the the you
put the your desires or your
expectations of that you'd have of both
parents onto one uh so I did that a lot
um and I feel bad about some of that you
know but I was a child and I was trying
to
survive and I didn't know um also was
blessed a lot man I had you know I found
fatherhood in the littlest of of of of
things man any adult that would even
talk to me that was a male like I would
remember things that they said because I
was just such a sponge for any older man
to spend time with me or to talk to me
you know I um I had a friend this one of
my best friends when I was younger was
this boy this man Billy and he uh was a
homosexual gentleman and he was a
fighter he used to do some prize
fighting down there in Southern
Louisiana very uh fancy fell too and I
used to run him run him around to buy
weed and drugs and this and that really
neat man um he used to cut his own hair
as well and so did I we had that in
common and he um he kind of became a
role model for me he was tough but he
was uh gentle at the same time because
he had that romantic interest in men's
and in pleasure with men's so I had I
would see him and and uh he kind kind of
he was older than me by about 10 years
so there was he had a lot or 15 years
maybe I mean h he might have been
nearly smilly pedophilic in some of his
behaviors but um but I I I just embraced
uh being able to be around him because
he almost had you know some father like
abilities he was tough uh he he cared
about me because he probably might have
had a light romantic interest but he
also was in touch with his feelings so
he was sentimental so I'll say that he
was he was tough but he was sentimental
that's kind of what I think a lot of you
know men desire young men desire in
their father so I got a little bit of
that from my buddy uh Billy before he
actually got peeled up and drove into an
embankment and he died I think in a
cutless but um I had another man who's
still kind of like a stepfather to me
today um I became friends with a kid he
invited me into his home and then I uh
me and his stepfather became friends and
um and he's still a really good friend
of mine today um and I value him you
know um I mean I love him you know he
took care of me for years man um and
showed me uh you know even though I
wasn't ready to take a lot of his advice
and guidance he was an example and
that's one thing that uh that was really
special to me and still is um another
man an older man one time told me my
basketball coach told me to get my high
school diplom get my college diploma
he's the only man that ever said that to
me outright and that stuck with me and
he said the reason you got to get it is
because they can never take it away from
you that's what he said and it was just
a man who said that to me but it stuck
with me so I would get inspiration from
some of the strangest uh strangest of
places man and you know and that's a
thing I think when you were young if you
don't have a father figure you'll pull
it out of anywhere it can be a movie it
can be a a song lyric it can be
a dream you know but you are really just
thirsty for that uh that guidance or or
or whatever you think a father would
give you and so you covet it and you'll
Chase it down anywhere and and in any
male authority figures uh or I did
anyway if a man showed interest in me um
even though I was still like a corny kid
and I was you know full of ego and
thought I was cool and stuff and or
pretended like I thought I was cool I
still I still uh I still probably really
valued um the fact that that somebody
cared about me you know so I would just
get it here and there man I'd get it
door too almost if I had to uh let's get
one more question here man then we're
going to we're going to pop off because
I'm I'm uh I'm tired and I I'll I'll get
into some other good stuff um and try to
honor my commitments to you guys thank
you guys so much for your your support
here we go what's up
hey man this is Luke I just wanted to
encourage you to continue
to work on trying to start a family man
I think you're a great person you're a
good human being you have a great heart
and I don't think there's any reason on
the planet that you should feel like any
type of apprehension or afraid to do it
man because I'll tell you what I I was I
was 25 well thanks for the nice words
man I appreciate you saying some of
those things Luke um uh I appreciate
that man it's nice you to say onward
about three years ago and I met a girl
who had a daughter and that that little
girl's dad had left her and didn't want
to be a part of her life and now you
know I'm her dad and she's seven years
old now and thriving and living a
beautiful life man but you know I wanted
to give you this advice Theo the
commitment you make it's not a
hundred-year commitment Theo you just
make a commitment a new commitment one
day at a time so every morning I wake up
I commit to be the best dad I can be I
commit to be the best boyfriend I can be
and and that's all you can do man don't
look at it as a 50-year race because
that'll overwhelm you man just take it a
day at a time Theo and and I thank you
for this podcast man I love it it it
encourages me to be a better person and
uh God bless you Theo thank you man
thanks man I didn't mean to cut you off
there uh but I appre I really do
appreciate the nice words dude um
that's a you know that's a great way uh
to to think about it you know CU yeah if
I think of something in a big chunk I
can't handle it you know it's the same
way that I deal with my with with
staying in sobriety so it's interesting
that you say that um that if I try to
think oh I'm going to stay sober forever
or I'm not going to have another beer I
can't hand that's really tough to
stomach but if I just think okay today
I'm not drinking today or I'm not GNA
party
today um then that's easier to handle
you know uh so that's really great
that's really uh that's great advice
that that that you're uh offering to me
man and I appreciate that and and I
appreciate I do get some good calls um
where you guys are offering me guidance
and thoughts and advice and I really
appreciate it uh you know it makes me
feel good that you care uh because I
care man you know we're out here [__]
fighting dude like it is for me it is
hard to be a man dude it's hard because
I want to [__] still be a boy I want
to still screw around and there's an
environment and a society that caters to
that it's like oh yeah bef you know uh
sex is everywhere and this is D party
and this and that and you can do it all
but you can't you know you can't do it
all certain ages you can and certain
times in your life but if you're ready
to if you're trying to grow up and move
on or evolve than you can't you know and
it's uh it's tough dude it is tough it's
tough to you know to not want to just be
a kid forever and it's tough to realize
you might have the confidence to be a
parent to somebody when you still don't
know if you've been parented enough as a
human you know if I still don't know if
I've found enough father figures you
know to get back to that to that
previous call I don't know if I've still
you know it's tough to decide side when
you feel like
you're you you're the child that you
were and whatever damages were there
have been healed or taken care of so
that you can evolve and move past that
so I think that's some of my issues
sometimes um Luke to get back to your
call um I believe it was Luke let me
check and see
here hey man this is Luke yeah yeah if
um you know it's tough It's just tough
sometimes dude but I appreciate that man
I appreciate that vote of confidence and
that's a good way to look at it and
that's a good way to look at any any
addiction or any concern like I don't
have to do this for for 50 years I just
have to do it for today uh so I'm going
to leave us with that man that's a great
thought you know that if you're worried
about something you know if you think oh
I'm never going to talk to my girlfriend
again or I'm never or my exgirlfriend or
I'm never going to be able to stop
drinking or stop smoking it's it's too
big of a
task you know our brains will do that
sometimes they'll make the task so big
so unimaginably big you know uh but it's
it's not true you know we just don't we
just it's just today just today you
don't have to do it for so I'm sharing
Luke's words there you know what's funny
is
man uh I wish there were times in my
life when if I had a father figured that
had come along and told me some of those
things things like that simple things I
think I wouldn't spend years years maybe
even decade spending my wheels not being
able to figure out um not being able to
figure out things or get past things
because I didn't have good advice but I
would gravitate to to it wherever I
could get it and uh and I think that's
what we're all doing these days um if
you're a young man trying to evolve
that's what I'm trying to [__] do
dude you know I'm having a deal with
these rap scallions out here trying to
use the grill at a damn residence in and
I can barely keep my [__] together
uh but I'm hopeful I'm hopeful man I
want to thank everybody in Sacramento
for coming out I'm going to sign off for
tonight man um and I'm going try to uh
try to honor my commitments to you guys
dude and I appreciate you guys being
supportive and hitting the hotline uh
I'll see you guys uh next Sunday night
and I'll um I'll see you guys in Phoenix
in person in two weeks uh you guys be
good to yourselves man try that I'm
going to try it you know I'm going to
try and take some of uh some of you
guys' uh wisdom this week so thank you
very much I'll talk to you later on man
let's get out of here with a little bit
of this is called Green sleeves epidemic
sound oh that's a little romancer right
there that is a little romancer
[Music]
boy
yeah it's tough to decide you know when
you got to
be you know it's tough to decide when
you got to be
a be a leader and when you just got to
listen and be a
learner my first thought all the time is
to try and be a leader but really if I
had to go back in
time I'd have been better off just being
a learner a lot of
times I'd have been a better I'd have
been much better off doing it like
that but I didn't know sometimes you
don't you lead because you don't know
what else to do you lead out of survival
you know but hopefully we get to a place
in our lives where we can take that
breath and let go of the and just be
patient with ourselves and let go
of the
controls and um and learn a little bit
you know and we learn from each other so
that's what I'm trying to do man you
guys be good to yourself man take care
of
yourself you know be good to yourself
you probably deserve it I'll talk to
youall
later have a good
one